foreign
[Music]
no more problems
all right let's go
Mamacita you need to clean the grease
the cause of fire it's a really good
accent we'll see you next week
come on let's go to the banana get a
blow it hey officers whoa what the
put the light down
what's up I'd like to report a crime
really call 9-1-1 come on let's get out
of here that guy
yeah I should have shot that
yeah take it easy
you get this job I blew the commissioner
why way city services when I got two
corrupt cops right in front of me
it's a guy this guy yeah back
off
[Applause]
how'd you get that number
wasn't hard yeah
who is this that's the lady down the
street
we'll have the fire
same thing could happen to you with your
whole family oh
how many copies
one
yeah you must have a Death Wish pal what
the do you want huh
there's people you took the money from
maybe you should give it back
why would we do that that would be the
best interest of everyone involved
really yeah well maybe our best interest
is to tie a cinder block around your
waist and throw you in the
Mystic huh let's do that
it's a good idea
stand for something Punk
protect and serve uphold the law
Justice
remember
up
tomorrow you'll have returned all the
money you extorted from those people
you'll tell them it will never happen
again you do that and this video will
never be seen
don't
and a half an hour later you'll watch
the uncut version on every news Outlet
in the area
I'm offering you a chance to do the
right thing
take it
that hurt more than the beaten
yeah
how you doing
a little coffee please
kid egg sandwich too
on a roll no cheese please you got it
I'll be back in a minute
is it just you are we waiting for
someone else
I'm sorry what
your hands if you really work the power
lines down their hands wouldn't look
like that I know we got to be waiting
for somebody else
here's where I could see him
we take a little walk across the street
me and you black Denali here we go
[Music]
he verified these instructions and I'm
gonna kill you understand
all right
[Music]
is this this is a scope
no Witnesses
[Music]
what the
let's go
what the hell is this guy doing
[Music]
hey Mark you've got a side front follow
you've got to see I got B
out nine yeah yeah live I'm on it
[Music]
I'd stay in there if I were you
who are you
everybody wants to know
gun's not bad just put the towel on
what do you want
I went ahead of the snake
so it's you
and now you've come to kill me
yes
[Music]
and tell me what do you gain from my dad
's face
this is expensive to buy
but I can purchase it for you
what is your price
a river
[Music]
foreign
yeah
somebody's birthday
my daughter
how old is she
she's five
[Music]
foreign
that often
been driving in the opposite direction
of Logan for the last three minutes
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
I took the chance that he matters
I'll make it simple step out show
yourself and I won't kill the kid
what's up
the wind makes it interesting
side mirror
two more third one goes to the middle of
the trunk
tail light
was the hair off on that one I might
have hit the kid
all right
next move Mack but it's not going to
make any difference
ah you son of a
you mack
you
safe Susan and you're not gonna save
this kid
is that your playbook
Playbook
Sue yourself
[Music]
foreign